Welcome to our organic farming video on
guava cultivation this fruit is widely
grown and valued for its nutritional
value in sweet flavor this video will
give you an in-depth understanding of
how these guavas are grown with great
care and precision ensuring that each
fruit is of the highest quality We Begin
our journey in the guava and guava
orchards in changua County Taiwan Mark
the beginning of guava cultivation the
cultivation of pearl guavas begins with
selecting healthy guava Sprouts these
Sprouts are carefully planted to ensure
they are completely attached to the soil
which is critical for their initial
growth and development when the guava
plants are about a month old you can
move them into the farm in the field
each Sprout is planted with Precision
maintaining a recommended a distance of
1 to 1.5 M between each tree this
spacing allows each tree to grow and
receive nutrients without competing with
neighboring trees once seed planted the
guava trees are provided with a drip
irrigation system which is crucial for
their growth drip irrigation is a highly
efficient method that delivers water
directly to the roots of trees
conserving water
and providing necessary hydration water
for the irrigation system is sourced
from nearby pumps and before it is used
it undergo filtration to remove any
impurities this ensures that the water
is clean as and free of contaminants
that could potentially harm the plants
if needed nutrients are also added to
the water to support the Healthy Growth
of the trees ensuring that they receive
everything they need to thrive
as the guava trees grow regularly and
trimming trees especially when they
reach 4 months of age is crucial for
promoting Healthy Growth and focusing
nutrients on fruit development removing
excess branches improves air circulation
reduces disease risk and promotes
Healthy Growth regularly trimming grass
around trees prevents competition for
nutrients and maintains the plantation
clean and free of pests one of the most
important stages in guava cultivation is
the preparation for fringing when the
trees are ready to bear fruit before
wrapping the guaves farmers cut the tops
of the branches to direct the trees
nutrients toward the fruit this practice
is crucial for producing large and sweet
guavas a Hallmark of high quality Pearl
guava s it's worth noting that only one
fruit is allowed to grow per Branch a
selective process commonly used in Japan
to produce higher quality fruit the
guavas are then wrapped in nylon bags
that serve several purposes the bags
create a controlled environment for
guavas protecting them from Birds
insects rain and sun exposure this
results in a more consistent and high qu
quity product The Waiting King period
for the fruit to ripen is about 1.5
months depending on the season during
the summer when rainfall is abundant
guavas are particularly susceptible to
perishing if not properly cared for so
the wrapping of the fruit becomes even
more important during this period
additionally while waiting for the
guavas to ripen the branches are pruned
per periodically to maintain the trees
health and promote better fruit and
production pruning is an important part
of the maintenance routine because it
helps manage the trees growth and
ensures that nutrients are focused on
the developing fruits as the fruits
approach their harvesting stage the
sweetness of the guavas is checked to
determine if they are ready to be picked
farmers use specific techniques to
ensure that only the sweetest and most
mature fruits are harvested this careful
selection process is critical because it
ensures that the guavas reach taste and
texture once the guavas reach the
desired level of sweetness it is time
for the much anticipated harvest the
harvesting process is carried out with
great care to avoid damaging the fruits
farmers Harvest guavas using scissors
and place them in trays to avoid
bruising after harvesting remove the
stems and thoroughly wash the fruits in
clean water this step is is important to
ensure the fruit is clean and free of
any residue that has accumulated during
the production process guavas are then
neatly arranged in trays before being
wrapped in a layer of shock absorbing
foam guavas are carefully packaged and
transported to Distribution Centers
before being sold to Consumers this
marks the end of the fruits Journey from
Farm to Market the traditional
techniques used by Street vendors
highlight the unique way guavas are
prepared and presented in Taiwan whether
you're a food Enthusiast or simply
curious about street food from around
the world this guava cutting skill
demonstration
is sure to capture and inspire you don't
miss this fascinating glimpse into
taiwan's vibrant street food scene thank
you for watching the video about organic
guava cultivation technology we hope you
found it
informative and enjoyed learning about
the process of guava farming and
harvesting
for
is for
e
for
stay tuned for more videos
on farming practices and techniques
until
then hello see you in the next
video do not forget to like And
subscribe to our channel for more
exciting farming documentaries thank you
for watching we'll see you in the next
video for
for